After all, it is their water right,
and if they want to use that water right to help the fish grow in the stream,
it's their right to do so.
But they have no incentive to do so.
So, working with local water trusts, we created an incentive to do so.
We pay them to leave their water in stream.
That's what's happening here.
This individual has made the choice and is closing this water diversion,
leaving the water in the stream.
He doesn't lose the water right,
he just chooses to apply that right, or some portion of it,
to the stream, instead of to the land.
Because he's the senior water-rights holder,
he can protect the water from other users in the stream.
OK?
He gets paid to leave the water in the stream.
This guy's measuring the water that this leaves in the stream.
We then take the measured water,
we divide it into thousand-gallon increments.
Each increment gets a serial number and a certificate,
and then the brewers and others buy those certificates
as a way to return water to these degraded ecosystems.
The brewers pay to restore water to the stream.
It provides a simple, inexpensive and measurable way
to return water to these degraded ecosystems,
while giving farmers an economic choice
and giving businesses concerned about their water footprints
an easy way to deal with them.
After 140 years of conflict and 100 years of dry streams,
a circumstance that litigation and regulation has not solved,
we put together a market-based, willing buyer, willing seller solution --
a solution that does not require litigation.
It's about giving folks concerned about their water footprints
a real opportunity to put water where it's critically needed,
into these degraded ecosystems,
while at the same time providing farmers a meaningful economic choice
about how their water is used.
These transactions create allies, not enemies.
They connect people rather than dividing them.
And they provide needed economic support for rural communities.
And most importantly, it's working.
We've returned more than four billion gallons of water to degraded ecosystems.
We've connected senior water-rights holders
with brewers in Montana,
with hotels and tea companies in Oregon,
and with high-tech companies that use a lot of water in the Southwest.
And when we make these connections,
we can and we do turn this ...
into this.
(Applause)
Thank you very much.